Trascrizione: chiara vit
Revisore: Denise RQ
(Musica)
É ufficialmente iniziato
il mese di novembre,
anzi Movember
dove "Mo" sta per moustache,
baffi, e "Vember", novembre.
Movember è la campagna mondiale
che invita gli uomini a farsi crescere
I baffi per tutto il mese,
allo scopo di promuovere il dialogo
e la raccolta fondi per I programmi
di salute maschile.
Dal primo di novembre,
molti Mo-Bro, I fratelli di baffo,
si preparano completamente rasati,
e cominciano a farsi crescere
dei bei baffoni
e sostenuti dalle MoSista,
le sorelle di baffo,
diventano delle vere e proprie
pubblicità ambulanti
per I temi spesso ignorati
della salute maschile
chiedendo ad amici e parenti
di donare su movember.com.
Dal 2003 la Movember Foundation
nata in Australia, a Melbourne,
ha raccolto più di 559 milioni di dollari,
finanziando progetti di ricerca
contro il cancro alla prostata
in più di 21 Paesi.
Movember è ormai diventato
un movimento globale,
quindi da Rio a Mosca,
a Trento, a TEDxTrento,
sosteniamo la ricerca,
mettiamoci I baffi,
facciamoci un selfie
e condividiamolo.
# TEDxTrento,
#Movember,
chiedendo ai nostri cari
di donare su movember.com
Viva la ricerca, viva Movember,
Viva TEDxTrento.
(Applausi)
(Musica)
Selfie!